Are you a materialist Christian?
Do you, despite what you say, see the
world through a materialist paradigm?
If you're a Western Christian, chances
are you do. And that's a huge problem.
In fact, it's the root source of all the
West's problems. Allow me to explain,
for this little-known topic goes a long
way in shedding light on why Western,
formerly Christian, societies have
completely lost their mooring and are on
the verge of total collapse. This topic
of materialism actually came to me only
recently in connection to the
publication of my book, The Two Swords
of Christ, which deals with men who, on
the one hand, were committed Christians
and on the other were committed
warriors. A combination that is so
utterly unintelligible to today's
Christian. Why is that? That's the
question. Why do so many Christians
think, on the one hand, that violence,
especially fatal violence, is the
absolute worst sin anyone can commit,
while on the other hand, thinking moral
sins, remember that word, morality,
are no sins at all. This, to be sure, is
a radical departure from how Christians
have always thought, right from the
start. So, let's go back to the
beginning and clarify some ideas and
terms before proceeding. As with other
religions and philosophies, Christianity
contains what we would today call
physical and metaphysical aspects and
teachings. Examples of the former, of
the physical, are easily recognized and
understood. Every Christian today agrees
that murder, theft, [snorts] and lying
are sins.
They also agree that charity, helping
the poor, the orphan, and the widow are
virtuous activities. Now, if you look
closer, you'll notice that all of these
sins and all of these virtues have one
thing in common. They all have a
physical or material dimension.
And the more concrete any one of them
becomes, the more do modern Christians
take them seriously. Thus, violence is a
great sin because you are physically
harming someone, with death being the
greatest of all sins because you've
ended that person's physical existence.
Theft and deception are bad, too, but
only in as much as they physically harm
someone.
If, for example, your theft or your lie
leads to someone else's physical
suffering,
causing them, for example, to lose their
wealth and/or property and become
destitute, Christians would agree that
the theft and lie are great sins. On the
other hand, it's interesting to note,
and this is the point I'm leading to,
how Christians take thefts and lies less
seriously if no one gets hurt from them.
At any rate, it's the same with the
virtues. Helping the indigent, the
widow, the orphan, are all praiseworthy
precisely because they have a physical
and thus recognizable dimension. You are
improving the material lot of these
people. But here's the thing. Christian
ethics are primarily concerned with the
metaphysical, not the physical. So,
let's define these very important terms.
Physical, or physis or physis, is a
Greek word which can best be translated
as nature, the real, observable,
material world around us.
When the word meta, which means after or
beyond, is prefixed before the word
physical, that word, metaphysical,
becomes a reference to all those things
that are beyond the physical, that are
outside the visible, natural, material
world. And as it happens, many of the
most important concepts that inform a
human's life, morality, abstract ideas,
notions of right and wrong, even God
himself, are inherently metaphysical,
not physical.
They cannot be reduced to matter,
measured by instruments, or explained by
physical causation. Take morality, a
word that was once as important as it is
today virtually meaningless, including,
sorry to say, with most Christians. In
preparing this video, I decided to ask
our friend ChatGPT to define it, and it
gave me a good enough definition.
Morality is the system of beliefs,
principles, and judgments that people
use to decide what is right and wrong,
good and evil, and how humans ought to
behave, both individually and toward
others.
Now, for the longest time, Western
civilization was governed by Christian
morality. What are some examples of
non-physical, that is, metaphysical
forms of Christian morality? Well, I
asked ChatGPT that exact question, and
it replied, "If by purely metaphysical
you mean moral norms whose wrongness
does not depend on physical harm,
material damage, or social injury,
Christianity certainly contains several
such moral claims." Chat then went on to
offer several, including idolatry,
blasphemy, and sacrilege. Of course,
anyone who knows anything about historic
Christianity, as it was practiced from
the time of the apostles to just a few
decades ago, see this video, already
understands all this.
Consider, for example, the seven deadly
sins: pride, envy, wrath, sloth, lust,
greed, and gluttony.
Only one of them, gluttony, which is
often seen as the least sinful,
primarily expresses itself physically.
The rest, while they can lead to
physical sins, are inherently sinful,
meaning they are evil in and of
themselves from a purely metaphysical
point of view, primarily because they
harm the soul, not the physical body.
Incidentally, isn't it interesting that
violence and even killing, which today
are seen as the worst sins, are not even
listed among the seven deadly sins?
That's because violence and killing are
not root causes. Things like pride,
envy, wrath, and greed are. For a
concise summary of moral sins, those
things which Christianity is most set
against, those things which most modern,
that is, materialist Christians have
lost complete sight of, one need only
look to chapter 1 of Paul's letter to
the Romans, specifically verses 18 to
32.
Let me read you an excerpt. "Although
they claimed to be wise, they became
fools. Therefore, God gave them over in
the sinful desires of their hearts to
sexual impurity with the degrading of
their bodies with one another. God gave
them over to shameful lusts. Even their
women exchanged natural sexual relations
for unnatural ones. In the same way, the
men also abandoned natural relations
with women and were inflamed with lust
for one another. Men committed shameful
acts with other men and received in
themselves the due penalty for their
error. Furthermore, just as they did not
think it worthwhile to retain the
knowledge of God, so God gave them over
to a depraved mind, so that they do what
ought not to be done. They have become
filled with every kind of wickedness,
evil, greed, and depravity. They are
full of envy, murder, strife, deceit,
and malice. They are gossips,
slanderers, God-haters, insolent,
arrogant, and boastful. They invent ways
of doing evil. They disobey their
parents. They have no understanding, no
fidelity, no love, no mercy. Although
they know God's righteous decree that
those who do such things deserve death,
they not only continue to do these very
things, but also approve of those who
practice them."
Interestingly, out of all those sins
that Paul lists, and I counted about 21,
only one is expressly physical, murder.
The rest are purely metaphysical,
meaning the harm they cause is primarily
to the soul, not the body. Keep in mind,
from the start of Christianity to only
just recently, the immortal soul was
seen as needing much more protection
than the physical body, since the latter
was already destined to dust. And yet,
how many Christians today, while paying
lip service to and formally
acknowledging the dangers posed by the
sins Paul, and by extension the entire
Bible, warn against, really don't think
of them as being that bad at all? As
seen, for example, Paul thunders against
homosexuality. And yet, how many
Christians today are welcoming of
homosexuality? Love is love, right? Any
Christian who thinks this way does so
because they are materialists, meaning
they only acknowledge the material
world. Despite what they tell
themselves, they cannot comprehend the
idea that something that does not
physically harm someone can be
intrinsically bad. They are relativists.
If this is how you think, if your
morality, your ethical system, your
understanding of right and wrong, in a
word, your Christianity, is limited to
the physical,
I'm sorry to tell you, you're not a
Christian. You're a materialist, which
is synonymous with saying you're an
atheist, despite the supernatural veneer
you claim to believe. Honestly, what's
the atheist's logic? I only believe in
that which I can see and measure, and
God and all of his abstract morality
cannot be seen or measured in a
physical, literal sense. Therefore, I
don't believe in God and all of his
so-called truths. Now, if you're a
Christian who says you believe in God
and his commandments, but ignore the
majority of them because no one is
getting hurt, guess what? You are a
materialist. You're an atheist at heart.
In fact, you're worse than the atheist,
for the atheist is at least logically
consistent. He doesn't believe in the
non-physical, he rejects all
metaphysical claims, and he acts
accordingly. His entire ethical system
centers around the physical.
Little wonder that the preservation of
mortal life is all-important to the
atheist. That's all there is for him.
Materialist Christians, on the other
hand, claim to believe in a host of
profound metaphysical truths, which, if
truly imbibed, should completely
revolutionize their lives and values.
And yet, when it really comes down to
it, they judge everything according to a
materialist paradigm, like the atheist.
Whether someone is being physically
harmed or not is their litmus test to
what is good and evil, right and wrong.
From here, I think we can go back to
what got me thinking about this topic in
the first place, the Christian military
orders, which I wrote about in this
book, and how so many modern-day
Christians are quick to denounce them as
false Christians, because they, horror
of all horrors, engaged in violence.
What's really happening should be clear
by now.
Those walking oxymorons, also known as
materialist Christians, are convinced
that the absolute worst sin a human can
commit is to physically hurt, or even
worse, kill another human.
That's because they're materialists, and
like atheists, they believe the material
life is all there is, and thus the
highest good to be preserved. On the
other hand, Christians from just a few
decades ago, stretching all the way back
to the times of Christ, while agreeing
that unjustly killing someone was a
great evil, also believed in a host of
metaphysical, that is moral, truisms,
many of which justified killing, which
in this context was seen as the lesser
of two evils. Here, for example, is how
ChatGPT responded in that same thread
when I asked it if the Crusades were
launched due to physical, or both
physical and metaphysical, reasons.
Medieval Christians, especially those
who supported and participated in the
Crusades, understood their conflict with
Islam through both concrete persecution
and metaphysical theology, and the two
were tightly intertwined in their moral
reasoning.
On the material level, there were real
and widely reported grievances, attacks
on pilgrims, restrictions on Christian
worship, destruction or conversion of
churches, legal subordination of
Christians under Islamic rule, and
episodes of outright violence. At the
same time, Islam itself was viewed as a
profound metaphysical offense, a public
rejection of the incarnation, the
Trinity, and the cross. This denial was
understood not as harmless disagreement,
but as blasphemy against ultimate
reality, made worse by its dominance
over lands sanctified by Christ's life,
death, and resurrection. In Crusader
logic, then, persecution and
metaphysical sin reinforced each other.
Muslim control of the Holy Land was not
only politically hostile, but
spiritually intolerable. Sacred space
was ruled by those who denied its
meaning. Christian communities lived in
symbolic subjugation to unbelief, and
false worship was publicly enthroned
where Christ was believed to have
conquered death. Christian moral
theology held that allowing such a
condition to persist endangered souls,
dishonored God, and inverted the proper
cosmic order. Violence was therefore
framed, tragically but deliberately, as
a lesser evil than acquiescing to
ongoing persecution, sacrilege, and what
Crusaders believed to be systemic
spiritual corruption. In this way, the
Crusades were justified by their
proponents as a convergence of defense
of suffering Christians, restoration of
sacred order, and resistance to what
they saw as both physical oppression and
metaphysical rebellion against God.
Now, if you're a Christian who does not
get this, does not get all this weird
talk about metaphysical offenses which
endangered the soul, or dishonored God,
or undermined the proper cosmic order,
chances are you're a materialist,
even if you claim to believe in a set of
supernatural occurrences that took place
in 33 AD. Before closing, I'd like to
make three more related and highly
ironic observations. First, do you know
what's another less technical word for
Christian metaphysics?
It's spirituality.
Just like secular concerns are
synonymous with physical concerns, so
too are spiritual concerns synonymous
with metaphysical concerns. In other
words, to be attuned to all those
metaphysical realities and morality I've
been discussing, is to be spiritual.
Yet, how many Christians today love to
claim that they're spiritual, while only
proving time and time again that they're
the exact opposite, they're
materialists. Sorry, but having an
emotional experience and feeling a brief
theological high while listening to a
Christian song is not spiritualism.
Second, today's materialist Christians,
who only care about physical
considerations, fail to realize that
there is so much physical harm,
especially in the West, precisely
because the West has collectively
abandoned metaphysical considerations.
In other words, there's so much violence
and bloodshed in America precisely
because, as a society, we do not in any
way, shape, or form care about
curtailing things like pride, envy,
wrath, lust, sloth, greed, or gluttony.
Indeed, our entire economy revolves
around promoting and glorifying them,
even though it's these deadly sins which
lead to violence and murder. Put
differently, even if all you care about
is the material, you would do well to
order your society around metaphysical
principles, which leads to my third and
final ironic observation, Islam in the
West.
As I have been increasingly pointing out
over the years, by virtually every
metric, Islam is, when compared to the
West, inherently weak, militarily,
economically, technologically, and so
forth.
And yet, destitute Muslim refugees who
reach the West cap in hand are
terrorizing the once mighty West, and
we're supposed to see them as an
intrinsic and unavoidable threat that
simply cannot be stopped. In reality,
even this is a byproduct of the fact
that the West, including most of its
Christians, acknowledge only the
physical, only the material. Had they
thought like their forebears, they would
have concluded that welcoming in a
people whose values and beliefs, that
is, whose metaphysics, are at complete
odds with those of the West, including
hate for and violence against those who
believe differently, is maybe not the
wisest thing to do.
But since all beliefs, values, and
cultures are now seen through a
relativistic prism that focuses only on
the physical, hence our prized word,
multiculturalism, there's no reason
whatsoever to be wary of or prevent
Muslims entry into the West,
even though their natural instinct is to
despise, possibly attack, and exploit
Westerners. Islam, then, is not the
cause of the West's forthcoming
collapse, but the stress test that is
constantly exposing it. A civilization
that has abandoned morality, spiritual
order, and truth itself has already
rotted from within, and its material
husk is ripe for conquest. So, there you
have it. Now you know why so many modern
doormat Christians are convinced that
the greatest of all evils is to
physically harm someone, even as they
ignore, maybe even celebrate, a host of
greater, though not physical, evils.
They are, despite whatever they tell
themselves, materialists, atheists. The
only question left is, are you?
>> [music]
[music]